Imamo pravna pravila,
to su ona pravila
koje imaju uleđenu funkcionisane države
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisane države
koja su pozvana čelo subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti
i tu imamo države
na različitom stepenu uglavnom.
A kod koordinacije
imamo isti stepen vlasti
i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili
i gde smo se ja da zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima?
Krenut ćemo sa ljudima da vidimo
koji to ljudi rade, šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čini svo stanovništvo,
taj državni aparat čine samo neke ljudi.
Ti ljudi koji učine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim
službenim ulicima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u imenu za računom državu.
E sad,
tim državnim službenim
ulicima se daju određene poslove.
Dakle,
imate određene državne službene ulice,
da te mu da rade neki posao
i taj posao predstavlja njegovu radu.
Ja se obudim
dok je ono što jednostavnije objasnije,
ne da se držim tih definicija i dužbenika,
nego najprostije je moguće
da ono objasnije.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom oblicu
i kažeš evo ti, radi to,
to je tvoja nadležnost, bukvalno tako.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti,
u principu
i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to je uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo i nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno u radu državnih
vodana, ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudija
koji je državno službeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno službeno lice,
da li oni radi isti?